одні з головних тем засідання ради
асоціації україн-ес стала уцінкою
європейськими партнерами готовності Києва
до супроводу зона вільної торгівлі з
євросоюзом федерика могерині швидкість
стала себе на воду you up іноді ти
українському криві відпочинок лиж і
декларації на світі за мало країн
політика комісії політично зубів я
зайняті криві ства України про проведення
реформ висловлююсь 1 км і так вже перуку на
їй у необхідності швидкого виклану
її нові кулі так і у нових законів до
всіх рамках та у подалі муп 1 корінь
реформ flames take на засіданні у
брюсселі український прем'єр Арсен
яценюк вид колірного про успіх та реформ
нас правді шафа neff стригов delete та
гірше тіл тому темпі я кого ви мага
євросоюз за крима кабінет міністрів вище
у сера до 9 у рудні apple однієї з
прямого ти законопроекти протримаю джед і
під від кори форму до верховної ради
про знайду статтю готовність України так
право Дженні зони вілліної торгівлі
з'їзд говорити та експерти вона
надзвичайно що україна готова
повністю на повній імплементації у всіх
покладемо по три в ній рок і київ по брили
навпроти над технічними деталями
однак такі аспекти я до прикладів
замовити інтелектуальну владу обидва
зоря конкуренті
що далекий вигляд тіла не комплектується
пахати при наймі нинішнє засідання
дав побачити на харчування з кутового
стропу столу погляду на українську
російський конфлікт нового хлопця з вони
супроводу зоною винну торгівлю
між україною та єс не будь попретесь
збоку Москви
такі результати міні саміту раді
україни з у брюсселя
перших усічення 2016 року відведення
просто ну сильну турнір любиш Україну
це з на буде шин на стіну по передні
основі b40 звільняти чисельних
економічних чи політичних претензій
Москви в межах біля води та у muse цієї
заміни ти всієї store по строгінський
стандарти на новий к-рую через плетем у
по ряду цих норм то забув я за ним і
перед сот засіки edition профіту
санітар не є нормою з простою до них
виступала російсько 100 руна на томі
квіткович а українські інтереси
український прем'єр повернув у vue
європейського кривляється на запит
монополії газпрому та
з арсеній яценюк за кліків брюссель за
блоку і проект будемо листя газу році
первинний шлях до 2 в обхід україни